[Music]
hey how much do you love your cats man
[ __ ] love my cats dude i have so many
cats that's crazy [ __ ] lovers they're
four cats bro
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] lover yep what would
you do would you do anything for them i
mean not really i want to get rid of one
of them
oh [ __ ] the one that's that bites
everything no the one that pees on [ __ ]
he's on [ __ ] i [ __ ] know the feeling
he pees on my wife too really
he'll just he'll just pee on her it's
the most random like an r kelly chat
dude
you got an r kelly cat i thought cats
were like easy to train don't you just
put the dirt this one is he's a wild
animal cat kick him like they found him
under a gas station in the middle of the
desert and then this lady rescued him or
whatever brought him to like a flea
market and that's where nicki got him
because nobody wanted him oh and now you
really don't want anything yeah [ __ ] no
how does nikki feel about this cat nicki
loves him cause like he's she's like his
mom yeah she has a pee thing and he no i
the wish like like only likes her really
and he hates everyone else and hisses at
everybody so it's miserable but he still
pees on her yeah he pees on her randomly
in the middle of the night too like
while she's sleeping she'll just be
sleeping he'll cry
is he sneaky he's like purring like he
likes the pet and then he's like he'll
just sneak attack it yeah this guy's a
predator he's a ninja sleeping the door
closed now the cat's outside if we do
that then one of the cats like matt gets
on the door and then he starts [ __ ]
howling all night and crying let me in
let me in dang i know the feeling have
you ever got rid of a cat before no man
i can't do it dude this cat is low-key
kind of cooking you a little bit he's
completely cooking me dude what are you
gonna do to get back at this cat i'm
gonna kill him you got a [ __ ] in his
litter box dude i want you to pee on him
yeah yeah that's what you should there
pee on that little [ __ ] shirt that's
like basically how my grandpa raised his
kids
you want to pee on me
the kids like one like he
he caught my uncle smoking a cigarette
or whatever outside and then he he took
one of his his marine corps helmets and
he made him put it on because way bigger
than his head and then he bought him a
cigar and he made him smoke the whole
[ __ ] thing
oh [ __ ] the helmet down yeah
wow my gran my uncle says he never
smoked again that's hilarious that's a
creative ass lesson he's like you smoked
that whole [ __ ] cigar just in a
[ __ ]
dude you'd be [ __ ] bleeding out your
eyes that's the worst
damn man that'll make what a [ __ ] g
dude that's [ __ ] funny is that
considered abuse uh i mean that's
parenting bro
or grand parenting you know what i mean
that's what the brand comes from
grandparenting has different set of
rules yeah if the cops come they just go
oh he went through the great depression
never mind oh my bad we're out see you
later fine sorry about that grand parent
different set of rules they got they got
passes for days
so a uh
a former australian
soldier is accused of storming an animal
shelter to retrieve his cat
and he pleaded guilty on money to
charges of the offense
this guy this guy named tony whitman
he's 45 wore full combat gear and was
armed with a fake assault rifle when he
barged into the lost dog's home in
melbourne in january right this 23 year
old employee pleaded for her life as
whitman tied her up and questioned her
about the whereabouts of his cat wow
whitman told the employee to count to
100 and he left the shelter without
retrieving his cat and the police
arrested him when he returned the next
day he didn't get his cat though he
didn't all that for not getting it this
guy's crazy he's like where the hell are
the cats huh
at a shelter i like the idea of him just
wearing full combat gear with a fake
assault rifle and then tell a poor lady
to count to 100 with her back turn so
that he can escape in time i just think
that's funny he's [ __ ] really funny
did he have to do all that can you just
ask like just make a phone call he's
like he's my cat there my cat that looks
like this yeah yeah
he had a straight rescue mission for a
cat but he didn't even finish the job
though he didn't even get his cat yeah i
think he forgot what his mission was
just midway he was trying to john wick a
cat he was like why the [ __ ] am i here
he's like i should go would it be badass
if you got the cat left that would be
johnny that would have been tight yeah
that was that'd been tight
then he would he would have done it for
a reason yeah the reason would have been
fulfilled sure this guy is delusional i
think well women reports guy needs to
make lists
looks like memento he's got tattoos yeah
get cash yeah he's rewarded he has bad
short-term memory or an assistant or
it's exactly like memento he's already
gotten his cat many times over but he
keeps on losing the cat yeah he or he
keeps on pretending like he's got to go
get another cat this is like when nikki
sends me the store and she if she gives
me like above four items and i don't
write it down i will forget the fifth
item every [ __ ] single time it's hard
dude four or less you're good yeah
that's it four four or less or i also
gotta write down and she knows that
sometimes even three [ __ ] me up yeah
dude
because they'll be like two or two of
those things are mine so i'll i'll
remember those ones and the third one is
her [ __ ] and it's some weird [ __ ] i
never think of like what usually like
jam i don't know [ __ ] amino acids bro
yeah some weird [ __ ] that i think you
know absolutely you know what that's a
lot of syllables to remember yeah throw
that [ __ ] away yeah that's that's a
tough one like what the [ __ ] is it for
they're useless skipper amino acids yeah
i buy i bought some kind of i don't know
some kind of acids but then isn't that
like like a is it like a vinegar like
they use that for vinegar
like liquid aminos it's like soy sauce
all i know is this chick sent me to
trader joe's to go get her [ __ ] amino
acids and then somehow i [ __ ] it up
because she always says i always [ __ ] it
up
and somehow i got barbecue flavored
amino acids
like trader joe's is that creative yeah
like liquid aminos is like a it's like a
healthier alternative to like soy sauce
exactly amino acids and barbecues i got
barbecue flavored some of smokey
barbecue flavors how the [ __ ] you get
smokey but was it pretty good though
well no she doesn't want smoky barbecue
what does she want like probably one of
the soy sauce ones regular amino acids
dude guys i just [ __ ] up you know you
know i do see dudes though like at the
market now just streaming to their wives
with the phone that's the usually
they'll just be like this one honey this
one that's because they ain't trying to
[ __ ] up i've done that i've done that i
don't wanna [ __ ] up hey but do you guys
do your old shopping like that
new smokey baby coconut amino that's
what i got i [ __ ] up yeah i'm telling
you man have you used them yet no she
was like she was like saying like she
doesn't want smokey barbecue she's like
i don't know where the trip is she's
like i've never even heard it try that
what is it for i have no idea bro i just
go buy the thing it's a sauce yeah
pretty much you don't want to do soy
sauce anymore a lot of people want to do
aminos dude i don't know it's like a
healthy alternative people are turning
down soy sauce that's asian hate right
now yeah that's true asian hate huh but
now kiko man they make their own now
they got their own amino acids
you know liquid oh they're adaptable
what about maggie i love maggie maggie's
bomb and is that even actually soy sauce
they call it seasoning no it's wheat
sauce yeah what's maggie it's like the
brand it's like it's french right is
that yeah i think it might be french
it's really good it's got a red tip uh
what is it it's like a french soy sauce
oh but like but it's a wheat sauce on
eggs i actually think it's better than
soy sauce hell yeah with sriracha yeah
kind of like dark soy sauce where do you
get that amazon baby anywhere let me see
oh yeah
i've never had that all right really
good it's really good it's just really
cool they got low soda like the low
sodium one like i think so yeah yeah you
don't hit this competitor
i will go for the green one over the red
but when i go to maggie i'm like give me
the [ __ ] maggie give me full maggie
on some fried eggs and rice it's pretty
good all right i need this experience
it's not spicy or anything yeah it's
cool no taiwanese sausages yeah where
did this whole uh low sodium thing come
because i i i heard that like it's
actually bad when you don't have enough
salt you actually want more salt yeah
you just don't wanna i mean dude like
some some of the campbell's soup out
there bro it's like [ __ ] 2 000
milligrams of sodium in one little can
lunchables is like that they're like
here here's your sodium for the week if
you eat one lunchable i think it's for
the american diet that's what it mostly
is yeah like that's that's what these
these protocols are for i never know
what's good and bad nowadays it's all
it's all dose dependent even [ __ ]
rice that you get in a bag that you heat
up or whatever it's got like 2 000 or
the 1 000 things of sodium in it what
instant rice yeah instant rice bro it's
[ __ ] crazy is that for like
preservation yes for preservation well
and they have flavored ones too and
that'll [ __ ] you up too i got smokey
barbecue like chicken flavor yes smoky
barbecue it's good for active people to
have salt if you exercise a bunch yeah
you sweat a lot so this dude whitman
reportedly told police that he suffers
from ptsd because of his military
service and somebody stole his cat in
the military he just felt like he needed
to get the cat back and acted without
thinking about the consequences of what
he said yo that's a problem man with
with how many uh military peoples we got
coming back and then they're not getting
the right help
a lot of them end up homeless if they
don't
so that's the that and then they're out
there trying to save cats and [ __ ] i
mean i i don't have anybody with a
specific military ptsd experience in my
family or anything like that but i
definitely have seen some of them movies
about like people that have that [ __ ]
like shooter and stuff or what was that
one or american sniper american sniper
that's one dude that was so sick people
got killed by a dude that he was trying
to help that's the saddest one like he
comes back and he's helping he's giving
back to the community in the very own
community and he's like you know not all
there ends up killing him which is crazy
so crazy what's the guy's name in that
movie chris kyle chris kyle dude have
you guys seen jesse ventura talk about
chris kyle he has a bunch of uh he
[ __ ] hates chris kyle yeah a lot of
people don't like that floor because
chris kyle lied or so jesse ventura says
about
um punching jesse ventura like to act
all hard
to see he like says that he punched
jessie ventura yeah and like because he
says jesse ventura was [ __ ] on the
seals which just was like why the [ __ ]
would i do that like wasn't he a seal
yeah exactly he was like why would i why
the [ __ ] would i do that ever jesse
ventura and he's like chris carla comes
up he's like that guy comes up and he
says all this [ __ ] about me
and it's all [ __ ] and like he's on
joe rogan joe wrong just sitting there
like oh i don't know if we could say all
the [ __ ]
oh cause his fans love chris kyle well
everyone loves chris kyle because of the
movie he's an american hero yeah
american hero kind of tough he's not
here to really back himself up so that
guy's just getting away with jesse
ventura is like he'll go
full russia like he's in russia like
he's just like i don't give a [ __ ] man
it's all about the truth dude i knew
steve had a good jesse ventura [ __ ] i
live in mexico
oh yeah i moved down to mexico
i love that guy dude i love i love this
quote from jessie matura after uh in
2017 after the five year legal battle
against the former navy seal and his
estate and he says uh
all i can say is my settlement is now in
the bank ventures and that speaks and
tells you everything else about it whoa
all i can say is my settlement's in the
bank he always has like that little
wiggly
chris kyle's estate and he won wow
he said that they were bullshitting it
was all [ __ ] because there was
because i know there was some stories
about him like shooting looters
there was like a big issue with that i
don't know what chris kyle yeah they say
shooting looters so jesse ventura says
that he thinks that chris kyle's
bullshitting about like some of the
stuff that he did while he was in he
literally says he literally denounced
the late american sniper author as an
american liar
and he feels vindicated in his five-year
legal battle against the former navy
seal what about the other seals won't
they there's probably other stories they
were all they were deposed in this
lawsuit and they couldn't back up what
chris kyle was saying and that's why one
of the reasons why why he won wow damn
jesse ventura's dope dude he's like a no
[ __ ] dude conspiracy theorist okay
i'm pretty bad but i don't know if i've
seen the dude but is this character in
the movie just eventually
no no okay he probably served it at a
different time he was an old school
wrestler yeah that's right he was a pro
wrestler and then he became a politician
governor of the governor of the state of
minnesota he was a pro wrestler
i think navy seal and then wrestler oh
wow yeah welcome to the rock
[ __ ] hella good connor's the easiest
one to do that's good [ __ ] don't brag
you